is any part of you still living at that
point no you're not living but this is
actually a really important discussion
we get really philosophical about this
um you're not living because life
implies metabolism and activity and
obviously we've stopped all of that
happening but you're not dead either
because dead implies that you've gone
beyond repair right you've gone forever
and that's that's not the case either
just as we've seen with the case with
skin cells and corneas and other things
that we can
they're not alive because they're not
functioning but we can bring them back
yeah just like like tom
brady you know
so yeah so death is not a clear concept
actually um at least most people don't
have a clear idea of what death really
is so we've talked about clinical death
that's just when a doctor says i declare
you well sorry not that's legal death
legal that is where a doctor says i'm
going to call you dead maybe i can bring
you back you know but i'm going to call
you dead i'm giving up at this point
because there's nothing more i can do
clinical death is different
right clinical death is just when you
stop breathing and your heart stops
beating that's it those are the two
requirements yeah but in the old days
that was death to people like before
about 1960 you know if we were talking
and you were so excited about what i was
saying that you just went oh oh and you
had a heart attack and you stopped
reading we check your polls so just like
in the old school section he's dead jim
that was it we gave up yeah we don't do
that today someone would jump on you do
you start doing cpr and defibrillation
we'd be shocking you and probably bring
you back so what we said was dead before
about 1960 we don't consider it dead
today we consider in need of help so be
so dead keeps evolving yeah the
difference what
what we call dead keeps evolving and
keeps changing yeah wow that's
interesting and today something you know
we had the idea of brain death to take
it further so in our view when someone
declares you legally dead
um you're also clinically dead at that
point you're not really dead in some fun
if we if by death we mean irreversible
you're gone forever you're not dead
because almost everything in your body
is still alive now you will be dead if
you don't intervene and stop things
decaying you know if you do what most
people do which to me is completely
crazy throw you in the ground beaten my
worms and bacteria or shove you into a
gigantic oven to be incinerated which is
just crazy stuff to me yeah at that
point yeah you can't really do that
you're not going to be repeated that's
right now what about this so
with clinical death and legal death is
that where they're then able to take
organs and donate them yes
so so that's interesting so after
clinical and legal death
you still have organs that go and can
live in someone else exactly
man that's a pretty good insight of what
could be possible one day and it's an
interesting point about that there's
also something called uh donation after
cardiac death which means that actually
your brain in principle your brain could
still be functional when they take your
organs out wow you got to be really
really
generous to do that
that's something they could in principle
do so this idea of dead is actually a
lot more complex than people realize
they often talking about crying and
saying well look dead is dead so it's
impossible well what kind of death are
we talking about here this yeah there's
different kinds it'd be crazy if you're
like edits you're you're like at a
street corner some guy's hit by a bus
and people are like he's dead and you're
like is he no you better that's why we
call the emergency medical services
because you know just because they're
not breathing doesn't mean that they're
dead yet
wow man
yeah it's interesting to to start to
think about yeah what is the idea of
death and when is it but we already have
three
two we have legal death clinical death
and then we have the point where you've
incinerated or gotten you know damaged
the whatever's left so badly that's
really
irreversible and to you that's really
yeah and we have a special term for that
which will sound very very highfalutin
probably because
some of us are philosophers like myself
so we call this information theoretic
death now it's not as complicated as it
sounds basically the idea is well
obviously let's say you're in a plane
crash and you were totally incinerated
on the crash
are you dead well yes you're dead
because there's no conceivable
technology that could ever fix you so
even if you gathered your ashes and
frozen nobody could ever fix that yeah
um but if uh
just take an example let's say that um
let's say that you're doing some kind of
nefarious thing you're thinking about
robbing a bank or doing something like
that and you you're kind of sitting in
your chair here kind of writing it down
on a piece of paper okay first of all
i'm gonna i've got to buy the guns here
and then i've got to find out how to get
through the the locks and then i've got
yeah all your plans you tell them a
piece of paper
masks maybe you look you've done this
before yeah okay
quiet shoes yeah exactly so you've got
your plan on this piece of paper and you
think oh god that was so stupid why did
i write that down someone's going to
find this you know the fbi has been
maybe sniffing around and so you take
the paper you shred it in one direction
you shred it the other you throw it in
the trash you think
okay i'm safe now no you're not because
if the nsa has been watching you because
they know what kind of guy you are come
on they probably are oh yeah they
definitely i've gotten a couple of no i
haven't got an actual mail but i've
gotten emails that
say i got to tone it down so they got
their eye on you so they're going to go
into your trash they're going to fish
that out they're going to lay it out
they're going to scan it run it through
a very computer very clever computer
algorithm and they're going to
reconstruct what you thought you'd
destroyed
and if you think about the brain it's
like a three-dimensional version of that
piece of paper you could do a lot of
damage actually to the brain you can
damage the cell membranes poke holes in
them uh change some of the chemistry it
doesn't mean that you could ever repair
it so long as there's enough information
left in the brain that some advanced
technology like an advanced molecular
nanotechnology maybe generate run by
artificial intelligence whatever if it
can put those pieces back where they
were then you could actually bring back
the function of the human being so
that's what we call information
theoretic death if you've lost too much
information there's too much damage it's
really obliterated then you're dead but
beyond that point you're not because
more advanced technology could in
principle repair you now we don't know
for sure that's going to happen but it
seems like a pretty good bet we're going
to get better and better at repairing
people
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two options
watch one this one or this one